JD's gonna smoke weed for the first time
weed for the first time that's right
we're in California it's legally with
his guides seth rogen and Snoop Dogg oh
well there's your company couldn't have
better company oh those guys know how to
smoke weed he's never smoked weed never
helped he's 56 years old how old is he
JB 30-something late thirties yeah JD
present yourself to jet where's uh
Jennifer he's 39 he's 39 yeah let
Jennifer see him take a look he's gonna
smoke weed for the first time give him
some advice you're gonna smoke weed for
the first time
yes I'm 39 years old you really haven't
yeah I really have not look at him you
grew up here no no no he grew it oh
you're in New York yeah do you have any
advice for him we'd just pace yourself
no Kim okay you're smoking it are you
eating it well I think that's part of
the process tomorrow we're trying to
figure out what how to do things and
stuff so right did you say Jimmy's gonna
help you well he gave me some advice
what was his advice said stick a couple
pops Yeah right a couple of hits couple
hits and see what happens it could be
the worst day of your life or the best
day thank you
that's what I'm worried about where you
live I know he's very pure that might be
the worst okay thank you thank you